we get it you love mommy that's fine
riding with grace it's ready with grace
because I really don't want to write
this whole thing by myself it's writing
with grace writing with me me my name is
Grace welcome to another episode of
writing worth great in this episode we
are going to take a look back at what it
was like to write with grace me every
week let's get into some statistics
about the whole writing with grace
process so the helloweb twitter handle
did a poll asking you guys who your
favorite character was and lace came in
third who came in first Marmee with 36%
of the vote yes that honesty about her
bowel movements is refreshing and
charming I get it lace did bring in a
whopping 23% of the vote you guys have
created some amazing ship names
throughout this series with a Harmy we
got Crais
we got banal mouths we got one of those
that you guys didn't create so much as I
created it because I enjoy it guess
which one it rhymes with Wow how about
19% of you have said that you watch this
series even though you haven't read any
of freak week and to that I say why
would you do that thank you for your
support but also go read freak week
it'll take a second plus a couple more
seconds what are you gonna do at that
time watch one of my normal videos do
that too here's a fun statistic every
single week there have been comments
about the theme song you guys seem to
really love the theme song and the
opening title sequence for writing with
grace thank you also thanks to Brian our
editor I know you're gonna keep that
clip in there Brian I can already tell
but now I asked you guys to forget that
that just happens but now I encourage
you guys to create your own versions of
our theme song cord yourself singing it
add in your own lyrics post it on the
that hashtag it writing with grace will
hopefully see it and remark on it all
right
there have been multiple people leaving
multiple comments wanting the big
explosion that happens at the end of
chapter 7 to be a giant fart yeah great
idea I'll definitely put that in you
guys also 40% of you have said that you
want everyone in freak week to live
happily ever after
so does that mean mr. Kevin gets back
with his ex tell us what you think leave
a comment yes or no or maybe no no
maybes just yes or no last week I asked
you guys to comment telling me how you
think freak week should end
and a lot of you commented just telling
me that you like my hair which led me to
believe that none of you were paying
attention and I'm ok with that
thank you or some reason I feel like
that won't be the case this week no one
to our challenge I took a poll with
myself earlier about my favorite
character in freak week and a hundred
percent
it's Kevin I'm sorry Kevin Kevin aka mr.
Kevin so in honor of mr. Kevin this week
I thought we should celebrate him by
writing a haiku for him or a haiku Evan
rolls off the tongue here is my hi Kevin
mr. Kevin whoa a man a myth we don't
know Kevin Kevin doh so this o is not
part of it that would take it over the
syllable limit so it's just so sit with
that pull it but let it affect you
change your life whatever then does your
high Q heavens
also a lot of you guys have been getting
out riding with grace post cards and
filling them out which is amazing hey do
you feel jealous and want your own
writing with grace stuff then click the
link in the description and send us all
your secrets I mean personal info let's
talk VidCon for a second
VidCon are any of you going no awesome
if you are going the Freak week table
read extravaganza is happening on Friday
night right before the fall screen movie
night the line starts in the lobby of
Hall D and doors open at 7:30 p.m. I
really hope that you guys come and check
it out because there's a lot of really
cool things that we are doing with it
that are gonna make it just a full
experience for everyone I'm really
excited I hope to see you there let me
know if you'll be there Friday lime
starts in the lobby of Hall D before the
movie night 7:30 be there be squared
make sure that you're paying attention
to my social media because I will slowly
be telling you some surprises that will
be happening at VidCon re freak week
live reading that's it for this episode
of writing with great do not forget that
chapter 8 the final chapter a freak week
will be debuted at VidCon on June 24th
and it will also go up on our Wattpad
page at the same time if you're not
gonna be able to be at VidCon that's
fine I'm emotionally detached from you
and your choices and the next episode of
writing with grace will go up on June
30th after VidCon in the meantime go
check out some behind the scenes of
writing with grace on the AT&T helloweb
channel and go catch up on freak week on
our Wattpad page Wattpad comm slash
braiding with thank you again for
participating and paying attention to
this series this was really fun if you
want this to continue in any way shape
or form let me know I don't know